it didn't last long
but it turns out the vaccine passport
may have been one of the most effective
tools to prevent the spread of covid19
by excluding non-vaccinated people from
indoor spaces
the risk to everyone likely went down
new research published monday in the
canadian medical association journal
says the unvaccinated have an outsized
impact on how quickly the virus spreads
the paper published by researchers in
ontario looks at the theoretical effect
of mixing vaccinated and unvaccinated
people
as the two groups intermingle more the
risk to the vaccinated goes up and the
risk to the unvaccinated goes down the
vaccinated act as a buffer to the spread
of the disease
despite this strong evidence according
to bc's health minister
there are no plans to bring back the
vaccine card that was dropped earlier in
april
of course these public health decisions
are always challenging right
when we kept the vaccine card longer
than anyone else we did receive
questions as to why are you keeping it
longer than anyone else since the
measures were dropped the public has
been left with the task of managing
their own risk during the pandemic while
governments across the country roll back
societal protections
infectious disease doctors say the
basics
still apply there are no provincial
mandates this does not mean that
individual responsibility in the era of
covet is gone this is this is what is
going to make us
survive the spring survive the summer is
if we all realize that kovit is not gone
and there's still work to do
erin mcarthur global news